Вічне місто Рим.
Здалека - краса неймовірна!
Зблизька - сморід і бруд,
від яких не сховатися навіть на центральній площі
перед собором Святого Петра.
Сміттєві гори ростуть щодня.
Жителі - такі, як Франческо П'єроні - просто безпорадні.
Франческо мешкає в районі "Монте Сакро" - Священна гора.
Утім, від святого тут мало що залишилося.
Міські працівники разом з мешканцями намагаються
самостійно прибирати вулиці від сміття.
Втім, куди дівати ці кучугури потім - невідомо.
Контейнери забиті вщент.
Нині тут тільки трохи місця у контейнері для паперу.
Решта опиняється просто під ногами, на сміттєвій купі.
Кількома вулицями далі сміття принаймні не валяється на тротуарах.
Але про це дбають не комунальні служби.
Щоранку ми тут прибираємо.
Інакше сміття сягає аж до нашого порогу.
Пекар не хоче продавати піцу із запахом сміття.
Каже: добре, що клієнти не бачать, як виглядає задній двір.
Тут накопичуються виробничі відходи пекарні.
Джанлука мусить платити спеціальним фірмам,
які все це вивозять.
- Рахунок за минулий рік сягнув 10 тисяч євро.
- Через те, що комунальники не вивозять сміття?
- Так, саме в цьому проблема.
Замовлення на вивіз сміття отримали три підприємства, з яких працює лише одне.
Це замовлення на мільйони євро, але робота не виконується.
А міська влада бездіяльно на це дивиться.
Тож, я себе запитую:
чи знають взагалі ті, хто нами керує, що тут коїться?!
Уже понад 2 роки містом керує популістський "Рух п'яти зірок".
Виборцям обіцяли кардинально іншу політику, яка б дбала про громадян.
Нині ж "Рух п'яти зірок" разом з правими популістами керує цілою Італією.
Відповідальності за сміттєву кризу популісти за собою не бачать.
Якщо виникають проблеми з вивозом сміття, наш рецепт простий:
нам слід посилити розподіл сміття.
Громадянам, які продукують багато сміття,
у майбутньому це коштуватиме значно дорожче.
Утім, що робити зі сміттям, яке вже накопичилося?
"Рух п'яти зірок" і тут відкидає прагматичне рішення -
блокує будівництво нового сміттєспалювального заводу.
Ті, хто все ще хоче спалювати сміття, може теж вимагати
телефонні автомати з монетками. Це вже не на часі.
Але сміття в Римі не розчиниться у повітрі, переконаний Філіппо Брандоліні.
Він керує міськими комунальними службами Болоньї
і відповідає за утилізацію сміття на значній території центральної Італії.
І це вдається саме завдяки сміттєспалювальним заводам.
Він вважає аргументи популістів наївними.
Риму бракує справних сміттєпереробних установок.
Десятиліттями сміття просто вивозилося на сміттєзвалища.
І ніхто не думав про спалювання або його подальшу утилізацію.
До всього цього у Римі кілька тижнів тому палала єдина сміттєспалювальна установка.
Прокуратура  веде розслідування за фактом саботажу та підпалу.
На сміттєвій кризі заробляє організована злочинність,
каже Массіміліано Корсано з  екологічного відділу поліції.
Раніше спалювання тонни пластику коштувало 60-70 євро.
Нині це утричі більше. Не дивно, що нелегальні оборудки
на цьому набирають дедалі більших масштабів.
У щоденній боротьбі проти сміття Франческо сподівається
на кардинально нову політику,
і що сміттєві контейнери на його вулиці нарешті знову регулярно спорожнюватимуться.
Хтось має дати нам надію, що цій сміттєвій кризі колись настане край.
Франческо не хоче миритися з тим, що похід до сміттєвого контейнера
щоразу стає мукою і що Рим програє у боротьбі проти сміття.